[Musique]
mon premier roman s'appelle vagabondage
éphémère c'est l'histoire d'un camarade
qui n'a absolument rien à voir avec moi
auquel on vole quelque chose et qui
décide de trouver ce qu'on lui a volé et
ce périple ce vagabondage va l'emmener
un peu partout le livre qui est publié
chez Kar édition circule assez bien et
histoire semble assez toucher ses
lecteur et ses lectrices et j'en suis
content et je voudrais que le livre
aille encore plus loin en ce moment je
suis en train de travailler sur mon
second
ran c'était chaotique parce que je suis
arrivé ici un matin d'hiver je ne
connaissais absolument personne je
parlais le français mais c'était le
français haïtien c'était pas le français
français et puis j'étais avec ma femme
enceinte de 6 mois et il a fallu
absolument seéinventer une vie dans un
pays qui n'est pas le qui n'était pas le
nôtre j'ai mis longtemps avant de
finalement réaliser que on pouvait
sortir de sa condition de déjà demandeur
d'asile ensuite de de réfugi ensuite
attraper quelques bout de citoyenté ici
ou là mais c'était pas
[Musique]
facile le pouvoir de jeanbert Aristide
avait décréter la mort de la presse
indépendante donc tout journalistes qui
ne prêchait pas la bonne nouvelle de l'
selon ce pouvoirl était considéré comme
un journaliste d'opposition absolument à
tort moi aujourd'hui 20 ans plus tard je
ne me considère toujours pas comme ayant
été un journaliste d'opposition ou même
ayant des affinités avec cette
opposition sauf que quand on a un
pouvoir qui organise des élections qu'il
organise et qu'il gagne à 100 % 27
sénateurs 27 sénateurs du parti 82
députés 82 député du parti on n' pas
besoin d'être d'opposition pour relever
que ce sont les élections truquées et à
partir du moment où on a commencé à le
dire le pouvoir a pris la mouche et ça
s'est fini finalement par des des
agressions des meurtres et cetera moi
j'ai eu la chance d'en réchapper mais
d'autres camarades euh ne s'en sont pas
sortis je pense par exemple à un ami
comme BR Lindor qui a été assassiné
lyché le 3 décembre 2001 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il n'a pas obtenu justice sa
famille non plus donc en résumé ce
pouvoir là avait décrété la mort de la
presse indépendante parce que cette
presse là faisait son
travail